hello I'm conclusively andrew heaton and
you're unexpectedly watching two mostly
weekly finale I know I know that's why
it's fitting for our final episode that
we just like I was saying for our final
installment it's fitting that we talk
about creative destruction it's an
economic term coined by Joseph
Schumpeter in 1942 to describe the
phenomenon by which a new innovative
product or process must necessarily
destroy the old way of doing things and
true to his word when Schumpeter died in
1950 he was replaced by a smarter more
awarded more American version of myself
here's an example of creative
destruction we used to have vinyl
records but records were replaced by
cassette tapes and tapes were replaced
by CDs which were replaced by mp3s which
are being replaced by streaming services
[Music]
creative destruction can be frightening
because in a free market no one is
planning anything it just happens
it's sort of like falling in love or
refer ting but you know what markets are
all about creating new ideas and then
breaking old models and making better
stuff as virile young industries gouge
and kill old grizzled ones new
businesses come into existence making
old ones obsolete
that's why there aren't roving bands of
unemployed elevator operators clock
winders and travel agents roaming the
streets in fact there used to be a job
called a knocker upper which might sound
like someone who walked around
impregnating the ladies but was actually
a guy who would tap on people's windows
with a pole to wake them up for work
whereas here in 21st century America I
get woken up every day by an Amazon echo
now we have professions that never
existed before
[Music]
by now most economically literate people
appreciate the concept of creative
destruction but the most common
opponents of creative destruction have a
Luddite perspective on modern technology
I don't know about this iPhone trend I'm
not sure how I feel about this
typewriter trend I don't know how I feel
about this wheel trend and while it's
easy enough to mock the people who
oppose the technological revolution in
the 1980s or the Industrial Revolution
in the 1880s it's harder when it's your
time period and your industry but right
now is the most important time to
recognize the changes around us what
areas are being destroyed what areas are
being created and why that's ultimately
a good thing creative destruction
manufacture America used to be brimming
with manufacturing jobs you couldn't
open your refrigerator without finding a
solid middle-class job assembling
refrigerators but those blue-collar
manufacturing jobs have steeply declined
since their peak during the Korean War
in 1979 almost a third of all Americans
worked in manufacturing today it's down
to 8.5% but America is still
manufacturing tons of stuff despite
opinions otherwise we don't make
anything anymore actually we do in fact
we make more stuff than we did 30 years
ago we make five times as many cards now
as we did in 1987 and our computer and
electronics manufacturing is more than
2600 percent higher it's popular to
blame outsourcing we're in American
companies send jobs overseas to what we
think are cheaper labor markets like
Wakanda but just as Wakanda isn't
actually a cheap labor source because
its economy is secretly thriving due to
vibranium outsourcing is also a red
herring the real culprit behind the
factory job slump isn't outsourcing it's
automation but do not worry about robots
taking your jobs fellow human for oh be
subtle and Swift and you may not even
know when it happens
creative destruction oh okay obviously
we all love cold I mean it's our
favorite Yuletide punishment or type of
char but the halcyon days of burning
rocks are rapidly winding down
particularly in the Rust Belt
understandably people whose livelihoods
depend on cold don't want to see mine
shafts getting the shaft and look
everybody loves miners some people more
than others but we can't be in denial
about the fact that coal isn't going to
make a comeback it's okay because it's
old times natural gas has surpassed coal
as the nation's largest source of net
electricity generation the time will
come when alternate energy is cheaper
than extracting dinosaur vapor and then
fracking too will die out and that's a
good thing
because coal is carbon intensive and
studies indicate there's a pretty strong
correlation between coal and coal
related deaths malls you know the place
where Roy Moore can't go anymore
nowadays malls are where you go to stock
up on tumbleweeds or feral wolves
that's because online retail websites
like Amazon have emptied out a lot of
malls why go to Sears to buy a pair of
capri pants when you can go on Amazon
and purchase I'm Nicolas Cage pillowcase
1,500 ladybugs that's right 15 455
gallons of Lube or uranium more also
less of a hassle to buy your vinyl wall
decal of half an Asian businessman am i
right or am i right but it's worth
noting that creative destruction isn't
going to turn malls into rubble while
old businesses get flushed out new ones
move in a bit like hermit crabs a recent
survey found that 30% of mall owners are
adding secondary uses to their space
besides traditional store fronts Orlando
square mall in Illinois put in a
trampoline park and others are adding
office space hotels and even residential
housing
so the question is would you rather live
in a world where you blow off steam from
your coal mining job by taking a taxi to
shop at forever 21 while vacationing in
a Marriott or a world where you ride
your $100 hoverboard to an uber that
takes you to an air B&B inside the
matrix while many of those good-old
meatspace human jobs were lost
we now have an abundance of better
cheaper and smarter stuff my iphone is
smarter than I am and it's more powerful
than all of NASA's computers during the
moon landing and while old industries
are wiped out like wailing we're coal
whaling entirely new industries and jobs
are created too but I get it all of this
is cold comfort to somebody who just
lost their job but when the Depression
hit the farmers in the Dust Bowl they
didn't just stay and drought ridden
Oklahoma they moved on and just like
then now we have to find what new fields
can provide livelihood for honest
hard-working folks whenever businesses
get wiped out by new technology people
freaked out but we shouldn't be afraid
of change we should be afraid of magnets
that goes for us to hear it mostly
weekly as we decide to tastefully
firebomb that which we've built so that
we may erect new forms of informative
comedy on its smoldering ashes I would
be remiss if I didn't thank the many
talented wonderful people Sarah and I
have had the opportunity to work with
and making mostly weekly thanks again
gang top notch so before we wrap up
let's show some of the highlights of
mostly weekly hay utility possible hand
is President Lincoln Douglas comparative
advantages
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]